what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation I know we'd be late to
this but thank you for being patient and
waiting for us because we got ourselves
a Godzilla X Kong title reveal AKA
teaser for a teaser trailer uh something
down the road the fact that production
is is underway I guess maybe I really
like Godzilla versus Kong the first time
I saw it and when I re-watched it
it might have been the product I took at
the time I was laying on my couch and
watching I was like there's something
that's almost so perfect about what this
movie is oh I I haven't lost sight of
that let's see what this 30 seconds of
Awesomeness is all about
[Music]
demise oh
[Applause]
what is that
the new and new I are Godzilla
multiplied by Kong
I like the hollow Earth I want to spend
more time I am so stupid
it's at Hudson
that's their new title that's what I
thought it was
now it's all about that subtitle so
there was a dude I was like
Oh I thought it was hard to lay it out
in the title of the video Yeah that's
what their new title is
read it right it sounds like Godzilla vs
Kong still the minion yeah does that
make it clear that they're supposed to
maybe team up this time that'll that'll
be how we tell them apart now is just
what letter you used to denote them
Clash
Zack Snyder really blew the doors off
with that one with with V with the legal
uh verses and now we have the
mathematical verses that don't make
sense I already forgot what it's called
the new Empire it's right there oh this
will be the Empire Strikes Back
[Music]
and then the last one will be called
Return of the Titan
it's not bad right that is not bad yeah
dude we're on tap if you need any more
ideas legendary and Warner Bros what
does it say here this latest entry in
the monster verse franchise follows up
the explosive showdown of Godzilla vs
Kong with an all new cinematic Adventure
hitting the almighty Kong and the
Fearsome Godzilla against the colossal
undiscovered threat hidden within our
world oh my God we're gonna actually see
Godzilla in Kong talk oh we need to work
together never you can't make me Kong's
all like wash out I'm feeling disgraced
after losing the guns
to help you after all that if you owe me
one person to be like the Rocky movies
where you know Godzilla tries to fight
this new creature and then loses in his
life I need to learn from a fellow ape
sure I had to take down this uh
presuming another kind of ape creature
it looks kind of like an orangutan meets
Sasquatch the Epic new film will delve
further into the histories of these
Titans their Origins and the mysteries
of Skull Island and Beyond while
uncovering the Mythic battles battle
that helped Forge these extraordinary
beings to tie them to humankind forever
oh my God away with the mystery now it's
time to become nothing but a lore dump
that's right I'm ready for it yeah man
I'll explain it away is more expansions
and more you know I don't know it's the
greatest fanfic ever that's the thing is
Godzilla versus Kong they did bring it
back to some of the more like Godzilla
king of the monsters has all that you
know cool ass looking you know Kaiju
fighting but God's over the Kong you
know they brought some of the fun in the
camp and the sort of Ray harryhausen
Spirit of it all back yeah and uh I hope
that they continue down that road
because as much as these are big tent
pole shiny blockbuster movies I think
you know the more we can go back to
something that feels a little more fun
camp to the right degree and maybe a
little handmade you know is always a
good thing for Godzilla and for Kong oh
Adam Wingard is returning right to
direct this movie he did the first
Godzilla versus Kong which again I
thought he was a perfect director for it
sure and uh whatever you got Dan Stevens
he directed him and the guests that's
right I'm excited to see what Dan
Stevens brings to this universe as well
uh follow Chen from Shang Chi his
Dreamcast there's a lot of women yeah
Rachel house as well who you've seen in
various uh character roles tiger joints
things like that IMDb surprise
surprisingly strikes me with a lot of
female presence here definitely are they
woken up my God so hello Priscilla
versus Wong because I just want to see
them talk to each other yeah I think
that's something that I feel Adam Winger
can actually bring wokism uh what no
what I feel he can bring more of the
kind of uh body language and and this
silent film kind of qualities that we
got with Kong I already speak sign
language
sign language
[Laughter]
that's how you be eloquent by being
elephant have the memory of an elephant
this creature I
feel looks like the history that they're
at least hinting at in this teaser is
that he has defeated prior versions of
Godzilla songs or maybe perhaps the
thing that was the missing ingredient
was that they didn't work together dude
and this is their thing but I am
wondering like how would they go about
this especially when it's something
where they're gonna be working together
is it just gonna be the finale but
stretched out of what happened in
Godzilla versus Kong with Mechagodzilla
or is it going to be like some type of
weird Team Up movie where you know like
a Hobbs
this is gonna be either the Hobson Char
they're gonna have to assemble the
Justice League of the Titans because
they got like you know we can get like a
Mothra back in the game other people
like maybe maybe that'll be it is not
only will Godzilla and Kong have to you
know have their Hobbs and Shaw esque
brawling but then we'll have to get
other people to join the team to fight
this guy who they have like a blood Feud
with over time because they're not going
to both be able to do it just on their
own well knowing the movies especially
of the uh you know other eras of
Godzilla sure Godzilla just kind of just
shows up yeah yes it's true they've done
a lot to try and narrative eyes Godzilla
the fight scenes happening and then
Godzilla just happens to show him he's
like I hate you what is Godzilla yeah
and those old movies moves like a force
of nature so it's like the people on the
ground we're like oh my God this other
Monster is here and then at some point
Godzilla was like all right fine yeah
you can't get guys to the choir he just
shows up like yeah I picked a battle
with you I don't know I don't like you
yeah and so whenever you appear I'm here
to fight you yeah so I imagine it'll be
several it's his they'll probably switch
it around we're like oh they have Kong
going in there like a weapon they have
Congo in there to go fight and then and
then Godzilla shows up or Godzilla is
fighting then Kong joins that's probably
all it's gonna be they're not gonna be
like I want them to be like actual
buddies
yeah I want this to be an anime where
Godzilla and Kong both have like at
least an internal monologue voiced by
Justin royland both of them by Justin
royland this would be perfect if we
could do that
oh Godzilla what's going on
this new creature is called a blorber
Gong it's a good thing Justin Roiland is
an all right guy he's he's looking
forward to clearing his good name wow
what do you think this creature is I'm
sure there's people who have already
figured it out it's a Mothman this is
every Cryptid in one
[Music]